[Music]  yes judge - yes no I don't I'm fine  thank you yep we are four smart  successful women I don't need a man what  is the point who still has any interest  ladies I am NOT gonna let us become  those people who stopped living before  they stopped living I would like to  introduce you to Christian Grey this is  for mature audiences certainly sounds  like us my butt tube in 40 years  that's impossible that would mean I was  only six this is gonna be a game-changer  can you get me some scissors I can't  feel my feet do you even remember your  last date we're talking Nixon era pretty  sure he knows you're in here  I don't care what society says about  women our age you are better at this  than you think you are the choice should  be ours it does open kiss me only one  another bottle  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]